(upbeat music)
- I love chicken nuggets so much.
- I don't like them that much.
- They're the soul food of fast food.
- Chicken nuggets are baked baby.
(upbeat music)
- I can't tell if this one
is McDonald's, or this one.
- This one is McDonald's, 100%.
- Oh, these are McDonald's for sure.
- I feel like you would find
this in like the dollar menu.
- I will say lowest quality meat.
- It was food stuff, remember?
- It tastes like sweet childhood.
- It has that processed
food flavor that you
know is a spice.
- Yeah. (laughs)
Puberty.
- It tastes like just the
right amount of like sodium.
And flavor.
- Look at it.
- It kind of looks like a dinosaur.
(crying)
- [Voiceover] So this
one looks a little bit
more promising.
- Yeah.
- It looks a little bit more cooked.
- I think they're Burger King.
- This one tastes a little bit more salty.
- Mm-hmm.
- It's got a little kick to it.
- If it's Burger King it's so good.
- This one tastes more like chicken.
- Crunchiness is just right.
- This is amazing, I
can have more of these.
- These taste saltier than this.
- How?
- 'Cause there's actually like a chicken
like, I don't know.
Like fluffiness to it.
And this just tastes like cardboard.
I don't know.
They're represented by a little star.
- At what age is a country do we stop
making food into shapes?
- Sponge Bob?
(laughing)
- They're headless stars.
- This is like straight
from the frozen food aisle.
- It's crunchier than the first one.
- For all I know this is a fish. (laughs)
- I'm just like peeling off the (mumbling)
and eating them. (laughs)
- It looks good, but it
doesn't taste as good.
- Because of the star shape
you have more surface area.
- Mm-Hmm.
Oh yeah.
- Because you have a star,
you get more breading.
This is the perfect amount of breading.
- Yeah.
- You don't need more than that.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] I know what this one is.
Chick-fil-A.
- These are my favorite.
Chick-fil-A I know.
- All right.
This one's definitely chicken. (laughs)
- It's definitely chicken.
- Yeah.
- The meat's good.
It's just a little bit too much
sodium for me.
- It's the perfect amount.
I don't know what you're talking about.
- I think these are still better.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] This one's
not as cute as this one.
- This one's just like all over the place.
- These taste healthy.
- Uh uh, mm mm.
- Reminds me of
high school.
Middle school.
Elementary school.
Cafeteria food.
- Tastes like microwavable chicken.
- This is sad.
- This is R.I.P.
- If that's Wendy's I'm gonna be sad.
- This one's my favorite.
- This one, which I'm guessing is Wendy's?
- This is the best one.
This is the worst one.
- [Voiceover] McDonald's, Wendy's.
- What?
- I knew it!
I told her from the (bleeped) beginning.
- I nailed it dude.
- I nailed it.
- I thought
BK and I were like closer than that.
(laughs)
But I think, you know
who your friends are and they just.
(laughs)
Slap you in the face.
- Always keep it with the redheads.